et la tragédie après la tragédie ce sont
les dizaines de milliers de personnes
souffrant de maladies respiratoires ou
d'affections cutanées que les médecins
ont baptisé le syndrome du 11 septembre
il frappe à new york les sauveteurs et
les résidents du quartier du world trade
center ce qui dans les minutes qui ont
suivi l'effondrement des tours et
pendant plusieurs semaines ont inhalé
des poussières toxiques
bertrand boyer c'était la fierté de
belinda son diplôme de détectives de la
police new yorkaise
mais depuis le 11 septembre chaque pas
est une épreuve depuis ces heures
passées dans les poussières dégagées par
la chute des tours du world trade center
contrainte de sa lite est fréquemment
elle souffre d'une fibrose pulmonaire
j'étais lésions aux poumons et j'ai
perdu près de 50 % de mes capacités
belinda fait partie de ces milliers de
policiers de pompiers et d'anonymes que
l'on surnomme les héros de la poussière
victime d'un nuage de particules de
béton d'amiante de mercure et de plomb
qui a stagné plusieurs semaines sur
manhattan d'après une récente étude
américaine 70% des 40000 personnes
présentes sur les lieux de l'attentât
seraient atteintes de troubles
respiratoires laryngite asthme ou
maladie de la peau nous sommes
potentiellement face à un iceberg et
malheureusement pour l'instant nous n'en
voyons que le haut inhalateur et casque
à la main régulièrement ces nouvelles
victimes manifeste en plein coeur de new
york
car jusqu'au début de l'année 2006 ces
symptômes n'avait guère à l'armée les
pouvoirs publics
il aura fallu le décès d'un policier de
34 ans pour accélérer les choses
les malades eux se souviennent des
propos rassurants tenus à l'époque par
les autorités
aucune raison de croire que l'air est
toxique
une affirmation que daniel ne veux plus
entendre
sept ouvriers gravement atteint est
inhalé les poussières toxiques des jours
durant et exigent désormais la vérité
ils nous ont mis sur une fausse piste et
comme il n'était pas avec nous sur place
en première ligne
ils devraient assumer la responsabilité
de leurs actes près de 8000 sauveteurs
ont porté plainte contre la municipalité
il réclame des dommages et intérêts qui
pourraient représenter des sommes
considérables